nikka bagsy goin zu den top-rockbands
sie gingen weiter, indem sie sich von kick semana
Frogger teen zone auf ego-selbst ehrlich entfalteten, die
beste frage, die uns je
obdachlos gestellt wurde, oh, es ist ein interview, das am
mittwoch februar kocht, als jemand zu einem
möglichen plaudern einlud rheinland darm
zwiebel nett  Person Hallo Jed, ich bin Krista von
click zoom, der Online-Talkshow, mir geht es gut
, nein, mein Rücken tut ein bisschen weh.
In Deutschland
haben wir ungefähr eine Woche, bis die Platte
hier herauskommt. Ja, das tun wir, ja, wir können die
Hälfte und wir haben gerade herausgefunden, dass die
Platten Nummer sechs sind. Wir sind gerade auf Nummer sechs,
die Single ist also das ist
sehr  aufregend, das heißt, wir könnten
vielleicht nach Deutschland zurückkehren und
weiter für unsere deutschen Fans spielen,
warum bist du gerade in Deutschland, nicht in
den USA, wenn Deutschland so wichtig ist,
ja, warum, ja, Truman ist immer wichtig,
ja, wir waren dort  wir haben  war in Deutschland
wir waren wir waren in Deutschland äh
das ist wahrscheinlich die am zweithäufigsten
besuchte Gegend Ich glaube nicht oh ja seit
dem ersten Album Ich denke schon die deutschen
Fans aber ziemlich treu also stellen wir sicher dass wir
wiederkommen a  paar mal jedes album warum
alpha jon-fen solo ist deutsch ein gutes
land für rockmusik oder sehr gutes
land oder deutschland ist bekannt
nur damit ihr wisst deutschland hat einen
ruf ja deutschland ist bekannt für seine
liebe wenn du dabei bist  Rockgeschäft für
Rockbands,
also sagten sie, als wir anfingen, du
musst nach Deutschland gehen, du musst nach Deutschland gehen,
er hat deutsche Wurzeln. Ich habe auch deutsche
Wurzeln. Ich muss
sowieso aus anderen Gründen gehen  Warum also nicht beides machen,
es ist eine ziemlich langweilige Geschichte, aber ich
meine, das ist die Wahrheit
und es gefällt dir hier absolut,
wir kommen jetzt seit 12 Jahren hierher,
ich denke an 12 Jahre, und es ist
wahr, wenn du eine Fangemeinde hast  in
Deutschland, ob sie dich lieben, solange
du Platten rausbringst a
Und so fühlt es sich an, wie Sie wissen, und die Fans, die
die deutschen Fans gerade waren, aber
sie waren immer sehr, sehr gut
zu uns. Deshalb kommen wir immer
wieder. Deshalb freuen wir uns, hier zu sein.
Wir kommen wegen Ihnen hierher  Hier sind viele
Deutsche, okay, und manchmal
redet man über Fans, und ich erkenne, dass
manchmal, wenn man eine Band hat, die
erste Zeile im Konzert ist, ja, wir, und
es ist jedes Mal die gleiche erste Zeile
im Inhalt, es ist richtig, ja, so tun  Sie
kennen die erste Reihe in Deutschland, die
erste Reihe in Deutschland, ja, folgt uns
überall sonst auf der Welt, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, da sind diese vier oder
fünf Mädchen, die uns folgen und
uns folgen, seit
wir hierher kommen, und sie
wir sind immer vor Ryan Ryan, jeder weißt du, wir
mögen ein oder zwei Shows, bevor wir nach Deutschland kommen,
sie werden auftauchen, wie wenn wir
in Großbritannien und dann in Deutschland sind und dann, wenn
wir Österreich treffen, und dann weißt du, die
Schweiz  oder wo sonst dann
sie sind auch da und dann kommen sie normalerweise
zu ein paar von uns.
Shows auch hin und wieder und du weißt, dass
sie ihre T-Shirts anhaben und du
könntest ihn jedes Mal sehen
und sie sind immer Regen für einen Iran, okay,
warum müsstest du sie fragen, okay, ich bin
Angenommen, weil sie Ryan mögen,
also kennst du sie besser. Ich denke, es
gibt viel mehr Platz auf meiner Seite, Leute drängen sich auf der
Mikrofonseite, weil sie Mike mehr lieben
als mich, ja, also gibt es viel Platz auf
meiner Seite, also wissen sie immer, dass es
immer offen ist okay  Ja, ihr wisst schon, und euer
neues Album hier und jetzt, was sind die
Unterschiede zu euren früheren Alben, was
denkst du, die eine Sache, die
wir bei jeder einzelnen Platte versuchen, ist, dass wir
versuchen, die harten Songs noch härter
und die melodischeren Songs zu machen  ist noch
melodischer, weißt du, wir versuchen
jedes Mal, wenn wir eine Platte machen, die Grenzen zu verschieben,
und es wird immer
schwieriger, das zu tun, weil ich meine, jetzt ist die
Platte einfach so schizophren, ich meine,
es geht einfach
vom Metal weg  bis hin zu Balladen
yo  Du weißt, und es ist jetzt an beiden Enden sehr weit,
aber es scheint nur so, als ob
unsere Fans das wollen. Du weißt, wir
machen es gerne, du weißt, wir gehen nicht
jeden Tag ins Studio und sagen,
wir machen nur Balladen  und wir
gehen nicht jeden Tag ins Studio und sagen,
wir machen einfach Metal, weißt du
, das ist das, worauf wir an
diesem Tag Lust haben, und wir gehen normalerweise hin und
her, denn wenn du mit der Arbeit
an einem Metal-Song fertig bist und  Du
arbeitest seit ein paar Wochen daran, du
weißt, Mittag ist eine harte Zeit,
um wirklich harte Gitarren und Geschrei zu hören,
und du weißt, dass die ganzen neun Meter und
und dann dasselbe, du weißt, dass
du zwei Wochen an einem arbeitest  Wirklich, du kennst eine
herzliche Ballade und du weißt, dass du
nach einer Weile ein wenig deprimiert
wirst, du willst zurück zu einem Rocksong
und so machen wir es, wie
viele Songs hattest du für das Album und wie
viele hast du  Wählen Sie, was immer wir gefragt werden
, so viel, dass
wir nur 11 Songs haben, okay, und  d
wir nicht, es gibt all diese Bands da
draußen, die sich 20 oder
30 Songs einfallen lassen und es dann auf das herunterbrechen,
was es tatsächlich auf die
Platte schaffen wird, warum arbeiten sie nicht wirklich
hart an denen, die du hast  aufnehmen,
anstatt all die Zeit mit all
den anderen Songs zu verbringen, die
ich nie verstanden habe, aber viele Künstler, mit denen
ich Interviews geführt habe, sagten mir, oh, ich
hätte 40 Songs und von den
Aufnahmen wähle ich 15 aus, du weißt schon
dass
ich meine, wir wissen ziemlich schnell, ob wir
einer Idee nachjagen und sie einfach
nirgendwohin führt, wir nehmen sie gerade nicht auf
, nein, das funktioniert nicht, es ist nicht, es ist nicht
so gut, es muss besser sein, du weißt
, es ist, du weißt es  Wir haben nur das, was
in den Müll geht, und du weißt
mehr, wenn es einen guten Teil gibt, vielleicht behalten wir es in der Nähe
kam auf diese großartige Vers-Idee
und dann bringst du das wieder rein und es
funktioniert einfach unglaublich gut und
man weiß einfach und ich liebe es, wenn das passiert
gut nicht so oft wenn sie
die beiden heiraten kann aber es passiert tatsächlich auf
dieser platte aber manchmal dauern songs
sehr lange bis sie veröffentlicht werden
ich denke mehr darüber nach  canterra von Paul
McCartney dauerte 12 Jahre von der ersten
Idee bis zur Veröffentlichung. Was war also die
längste Zeit mit einem Ihrer Songs
? Das ist eine großartige Frage. Vielen Dank
Ich mag eines der längsten,
es muss sein, ich werde sagen, ich werde
sagen, ich werde sagen, es hat die richtigen
Gründe,
und wir hatten es von mm, also haben wir wahrscheinlich fünf
oder sechs Jahre nächster Kandidat nächster
Kandidat gejammt  bevor wir
geschrieben haben wir haben zu viele platten gemacht wir haben zu viele
alben gemacht ich denke es ist ja der nächste kandidat
aus den richtigen gründen glaube nicht denkt er
hat sechs jahre ich denke das ist das längste was
wir haben und während wir jetzt weiter rasen  mit
deinem neuen al  Penner, wäre es treu,
wie funktioniert deine Kristallkugel, weil
meine Kristallkugeln im Laden, wie ist es mit
dir? Ich bin nie
die Kristallkugeln. Okay, ich weiß nicht, wir
wie wenn du
einen Song schreibst wenn du schreibst wie du
weißt woran du mich erinnerst oder die
Fotos oder der Rockstar oder irgendeine
dieser Arten von Songs weißt du,
was ein Hit wird und wir nicht okay, du
weißt manchmal wir  Ich weiß nicht einmal, dass
es eine Single wird, du weißt, wir machen sie einfach,
und wenn sie großartig ankommen, weißt du,
wenn nicht, würdest du einfach weiter Musik machen,
solange die Leute es hören wollen, und
du weißt, ich weiß nicht, ob das gerecht ist  lässt
uns so klingen, als wüssten wir nicht, was wir
tun, wir machen einfach nur Spaß, aber das ist
seltsam, aber es ist wahr, ja, ich weiß, es gab
Zeiten, in denen ich mich zurücklehnte und
mir dachte, dieser Song ist großartig
Song und unsere Fans werden ihn
genauso lieben, wie wir es lieben, ihn zu machen, und er
läuft auf Anhieb und geradeaus  Down Ich bin
wie nein Ich werde einfach aufhören zu versuchen
vorherzusagen und einfach Musik machen und wir werden
sehen, was passiert und das ist alles in Ordnung, also
wünsche ich dir alles Gute. Danke, danke
, danke, vielen Dank